alright Michael Seibel so today we're
gonna do something different and talk
about a few of the essays you've worked
on in the past I think these are maybe
the past two years yes so the first one
is why should I star startup you start
this essay by saying a lot of people ask
themselves this question
they often mull over one of the one or
more of the following facts one the vast
majority of startups are not successful
- for talented technical people it's
relatively easy to get a job and make a
large salary and three large companies
offer opportunities to work on very
difficult problems that only often occur
at scale my answer to why you should
start a start-up is simple there's a
certain type of person who only works at
their peak capacity when there is no
predictable path to follow the odds of
success are low and they have to talk to
and they have to take personal
responsibility for failure the opposite
of most jobs at a large company yes okay
why did you write this essay so I think
that um there are two reasons one I
talked to a lot of smart technical
people yeah who I think sometimes feel
like they should start a startup but
they're conflicted because they either
don't know if they have a good idea
don't have an idea don't have a team and
I think they're really trying to figure
out like what should with my life you
know like what should my real career
path be and when I first started giving
people advice I think that I really
assume that because you could sort of
start up you should start a startup
mm-hmm
you know if you have the money to afford
if you have the time if you have the
ability you should be doing it I quickly
realized working at YC that's a bad idea
and I think what I quickly realized is
that there's probably like three sets of
people okay
there's probably the set of people who
the only thing they can really do is
work in a radically entrepreneurial job
yeah like literally like they will not
enjoy their life inside of a big company
inside a big rock or see like and I
think like back in the day like those
are the kind of people who start small
businesses huh and so there's that type
of people
and like they're relatively few and far
between like I wouldn't be surprised if
that's only like 1% of the population
yeah the second group people are the
people who are on the fence mm-hmm they
want to be really challenged by work but
they can easily apply themselves in
either a entrepreneurial world or in a
big company world and I think those
people are the ones were like they have
some choices to make yeah you know yeah
I think a lot of people confuse
themselves for this group when in
reality and this group is also probably
pretty small and then there's a last
group pretty small how small like I bet
I bet 1% like I bet there's only really
well so far yeah I think it's a really
small group who can actually be equally
capable in either in either role as a
founder or as a really effective person
inside of a big company huh and I think
you do see this like it I think you do
see like founders who get acquired who
are actually a really functional inside
of big companies and vice versa
right exactly go on start companies they
do well but few and far between I think
the last group is by far the biggest
group are the people who are gonna
operate best within a large company and
like the mindset of this type of person
is type of person at least from what
I've seen it's like they want a system
to optimize like they want an existing
system an existing path an existing set
of rules they can operate and play play
by and like what's interesting is that
like almost everything up to this point
in your life kind of has that Yeah right
like kindergarten through 12 has this
even college has this and they kind of
want to continue that someone else
defines what's in a and what's in F and
then I optimized right and I don't think
that there's any like moral judgment to
be passed like I think that like if most
people didn't feel that way the world
wouldn't work so it's like a good thing
but there's this mug of people who feel
like I want to make the rules yeah I
don't want to follow them yeah and so I
think that like when someone's think
about whether they start startup they
should really be intellectually honest
with themselves about which of these
groups they're in and anyone who's
trying to kind of guilt trip them into
one group or another right like it goes
both ways like I in the past would go
she people to do a fountain to be a
founder you have a lot of people parents
will guilt trip them into being a big
company or being a doctor or Yetta Yetta
Yetta I just think like this is one of
these things where you have to actually
have some personal you have to go deep
and really understand yeah did you ever
read the book the e-myth no I haven't
have you heard of this book no no no so
I read it in college so it's been a
while but basically the concept was a
lot of people who are you could say
craftsmen yes so in our context like a
developer yeah I often think that they
want to become entrepreneurs so they
could do just their craft in just the
way they want to but they don't realize
that as soon as they enter the
entrepreneurial realm yeah most of their
jobs no longer and so I think I think
this is a common thing and it's why
these indie hackers are so like people
love them so much it's interesting point
because like artists and craftsmen
doesn't equal founder isn't it and even
more so what's so sad is that as a
founder almost by definition the thing
that you're good at is the thing that
you stop doing oh yeah
and like you have to keep on doing
things that you suck okay with it
yeah no it's rare that the founder who's
really good at something can like
delegate so well that the thing they
love is still the thing they do yeah so
okay you you get to this at the end what
are the questions you know that we've
had some time since you wrote this one
yeah so what what are the questions that
you ask yourself when you have to decide
if you're in that do you know 2% of
people um I can answer this for myself
better the questions that I asked myself
was where am I at my best mm-hmm and
where do I feel like I am organically
applying effort like I'm 100%
self-motivated and like I think anyone
who is 20 to 25 has enough life
experience to know and certainly anyone
who's 30 or 30 plus it definitely is
enough life experience to know you know
in what types of situations in my I'll
just naturally extremely motivated the
other kind of question I asked which is
an extension of this is like if I think
about the moments where I outperform
so not only was I released from than one
of it but actually like delivered the
best results I did the best where does
that happen mmm and like when I think
about those moments for myself like they
never really happened in the truly
structured things like in the k-12
setting I did fine all that stuff of
course right I did all the classes and
got all the grades but it wasn't when I
was like really like kicking into high
gear yeah so I think if you're like
super honest with like when do you
really kick it into high gear that's
when like you can start asking this
question of yourself like okay who
should I be mmm and what career track
should I take I think that like one
tricky bit here is you have to be really
careful about taking advice from biased
people so I eat everyone yeah right like
when I was giving founders this advice
originally I was so biased I was like
well I'm at YC I want you to be a
founder like you should be a founder
right I was giving you advice I was you
know previously giving advice those are
self-serving I think that like a lot of
young people are looking for advice
givers and are not doing a job of
identifying bias and so I see a lot of
people who are generally believing the
information that they get from either
their peers or from companies that they
work at and like they don't realize
those people are biased
a perfect example my brothers at MIT
right now the most prestigious jobs are
jobs of Facebook and Google and that
prestige has actually very little to do
with any facts like it actually reminds
me of like when I was in high school and
like the crew that I was in the like job
everyone wanted to do was be a lawyer
and as we were all like government kids
they everyone would be a lawyer but then
if you ask people like do you actually
want to do the work of a lawyer I'd be
like no of course not yeah yeah yeah and
like I want to like you know change the
laws and I want to like debate the
Constitution and write all these things
like yeah but do you actually want to do
the lawyer you're like just driving
model
exactly as a model unity right and so I
think like similarly when I talk to my
brother and I like go to MIT I meet all
these people who have this create this
imaginary world where when they get to
go to Google they're gonna be on the
machine learning team and they're going
to have high impact from day one and
like needless to say Google loves to
pitch this story right and like people
love to eat it but the reality is when
you're on the other side that's often
very rarely the case yeah and so what I
would what I would encourage people to
do having been an offender myself is to
just really look for the bias in the
person who's presenting you with options
and advice like understand where their
biases are and understand that like
Google is operating a machine and the
Machine has multiple purposes one
purpose is to get the smartest people to
work on the hardest tasks but the other
purpose is to get people who are smart
and talented so that they're not working
for Google's competitors and then the
last purpose is to get people who are
smart and talented so they're not
creating companies that will compete
with Google yeah and everyone
understands the first one and they don't
think about two and three No and also
when when I find college kids and I'm
totally offender of this as well they
seek people for advice until the person
gives them advice that corroborates with
what they want to hear yeah and so you
just look around sometimes it feels like
you got you got to do some living like
you can only listen to advice or so long
well and I think the peer advice thing
is actually really tricky it's really
hard to go from like I'd argue that like
in school especially like K to 12 a lot
of peer advice is very helpful like I
learned how to apply to a good school
from my peers like my parents hadn't
done it in years right I learned which
classes to take which teachers were good
right I like my peers were this like
great intelligence source for so long
and then it turns out that like with
career advice they almost are look
horrible and I think it's so hard to
from like a situation where someone goes
from a good source of information to a
bad source mission so fast but like
that's what happens in college like your
peers are no longer because like I think
what the reality is is that like in many
ways there's a simple track and a simple
set of rails yeah all the way up through
college of court and then college it
goes from like one track to a thousand
tracks yeah and like your peers don't
even know anything about any of the
8,000 tracks so suddenly they're like
not the experts anymore
something the kid who's like one year
ahead of you really just doesn't
actually know anything more than you do
no but like your whole old system is
still there your old system of like
relying on that is still there and it's
what's funny is the big companies know
this like that's the cool thing oh yeah
they are actually relying on you having
poor sources information like I
everything that a big company does to
attract a college kid is 100%
orchestrated mm-hmm yeah I mean there's
an information gap there yes yeah
and that's how the business works I mean
it's fine again like you can go and have
fun of these jobs you can go and feel
horrible what I regularly for most
people that is the job they should take
yeah but like man if you're one of those
different people don't believe the hype
I mean this is kind of harsh and yeah I
don't know if it's a hundred inaccurate
but my impression is that the world just
kind of tends toward wanting you to be
average you ask someone for advice they
like these are the known outcomes based
on all the inputs you just gave me you
should go work at this company and I
wouldn't say average I would say like
wants to put you in a box
there could be a very productive box
right it could be like ridiculously
productive box but like a well laid out
well understood box like an ax plug you
in somewhere move on yeah and that
doesn't work for some people
yeah yeah well more importantly like for
some people that's not how you get there
best for some people it's almost a
guarantee you won't get there best in
that environment and so yeah so what's
so weird is like we're not talking about
like do you see a good business
opportunity or do you see do you have
like the
like burning problem like those things
are important but man if you are not
irrationally motivated to do startups
and be entrepreneurial like it's going
to be frustrating and you're not going
to understand the risk reward yeah
because like from a pure money-making
perspective it's probably better to take
the job at Google
it's definitely safer definitely safer
yeah but from me like will I enjoy my
life perspective like that's the one
where like for some people absolutely
not right yeah but on the other hand I
just say try it out see how you feel
like you can do plenty of projects in
college again you can see how it works
yeah yeah cool
you